at the age of nine he knew what he
wanted to do with his life and he never
wavered from that goal now he's one of
the world's most famous scientists he's
earned the title of most powerful nerd
in the universe from National Public
Radio and the title of the world's
sexiest astrophysicist from People
magazine he was also instrumental in
cutting down the number of planets in
our solar system and in doing so he
upset an entire generation who had come
to love Pluto as the small quirky planet
and well who is this icon of science
that's recognizable by the general
populace well of course it's neil
degrasse tyson
Dyson was born in New York City in 1959
and he grew up in the Bronx his mother
worked for the US Department of Health
Education and Welfare and his father
worked for the city of New York Tyson he
was a star student at the Bronx High
School of Science well before beginning
at the Bronx High School of Science they
Tyson had decided that science was the
path that he wants to follow with his
life when he was in elementary school
Tyson's class took a field trip to the
Hayden Planetarium while there he felt
that he was literally called to a career
in science so strong was that imprint of
the night sky that I'm certain that I
had no choice in the matter
that in fact the universe called me
Tyson immediately began committing time
to his newfound interest and some might
say obsession and his time in high
school showed his dedication to the
study of the stars while attending the
Bronx High School of Science Tyson was a
wrestler but he devoted much time to his
studies he was the editor of the
physical science journal and regular
classes they weren't enough for him he
actually took classes at the very place
that sparked his interest in
astrophysics the Hayden Planetarium
after school he spent time observing the
sky the moon the stars all from the roof
of his home in New York his dedication
to science and academics during his
teenage years grabbed the attention of
some very prominent people one of these
well you might have heard of him as Carl
Sagan when it came time for Tyson to
apply to college Cornell was among the
schools that he applied to the Sagan was
a professor at Cornell and the
admissions office made sure he was sent
a copy of Tyson's application after they
saw the talent and potential that was
within this aspiring scientist Sagan was
duly impressed by what Tyson had written
in his application so much so that he
invited Tyson to spend a day at Cornell
Tyson he remembers that day in 1975 as
one of the most formative days of his
life
Sagan well he died in 1996 and Tyson
came into possession of his datebook
which includes the notation
Neil Tyson on the square for December
20th 1975 the two science minded men
spend the day together
touring Cornell's labs and discussing
the mysteries of the universe Sagan
gifted Tyson with a copy of the book the
cosmic connection inscribing it's to
indicate his prediction and
for Tyson's career to a future
astronomer Tyson never forgot what he
learned from Sagan that day and the
lessons he took back to the Bronx with
him were more than just the scientific
method I already knew I wanted to become
a scientist but that afternoon I learned
from Carl the kind of person I wanted to
become he reached out to me and to
countless others inspiring so many of us
to study teach and do science science is
a cooperative Enterprise spanning the
generations a few months after his visit
to Cornell
Tyson graduated from the Bronx High
School of Science even though his visit
with se caen had a profound impact on
his life Tyson opted not to attend
Cornell but as an excellent students he
had no shortage of prominent schools to
choose from though Cornell wasn't the
right fit for him Harvard was Tyson
entered Harvard as an undergraduate in
the fall of 1976 as a students he paid
his tuition partially through grants and
scholarships but also through a
work-study program part of Tyson's work
requirement was to clean bathrooms on
campus including those of the other
students on a Larry King Live appearance
he described the experience as a little
weird but he was willing to do it to pay
his way through school and to achieve
his dreams working and studying physics
weren't enough to occupy the active and
curious Tyson though he was on the crew
team and the wrestling team while he was
at Harvard and he was also a jazz
speller in Latin dancer he graduated
from Harvard in 1980 with a degree in
physics and kept his academic career
moving forward with an acceptance to the
University of Texas for a master's
program he completed his MA in astronomy
in 1983 and he intended to pursue a
doctorate from the college but well
here's a roadblock and Tyson himself
admits that the roadblock was largely of
his own making looking back he has
admitted that he didn't devote as much
time to doing lab research during his
graduate years as he should have been
could've and this prevented him from
being able to go right from his master's
program to earning a doctoral degree he
even had professors tell him to stop
working in the field of astronomy at one
point struggling as a student and broke
Tyson considered a very different job
than that of a professor or museum
director he thought about becoming an
erotic dancer he even went so far as to
go to a show to see if he could do it
when the dancers came out and their
skimpy undergarments were lit up as they
generated to a rendition of great balls
of fire
Tyson decided that no matter how broke
he was exotic dancing well it wasn't
very thankfull EEP for the scientific
community though Tyson's break from
academics it was short lived with his
undergraduate achievements and a start
on a graduate degree he was able to land
a teaching job at the University of
Maryland and eventually he found his way
back onto the doctoral track in the Ivy
League in 1991
fifteen years after scrubbing toilets to
pay for his undergraduate degree Tyson
graduated from Columbia University with
a doctorate in astrophysics he then
studied in the Ivy League system moving
to Princeton for a postdoctoral position
while he was earning his degrees and
moving his way up the academic ladder
Tyson was publishing articles and
writing a column for stardate a science
magazine published by the University of
Texas while he was attending Columbia he
also worked under a professor who was
supportive of Tyson's ambitions and
intellect applying for grants that gave
Tyson access to the International
Astronomy community Tyson he traveled
throughout Europe attending meetings and
learning from the best and brightest in
the field from all around the world
Tyson's own styie it was also beginning
to rise soon after graduating from
Columbia well he landed his dream job
and yeah that was a position back at the
Hayden Planetarium where his dreams had
started he started out as a staff
scientist but it was off to one year
that he was named acting director of the
planetarium then only one more year
later he was formally named the director
of the Hayden Planetarium early on in
his tenure in director he made updating
and modernizing the facility a blue
stone of his work at Hayden the project
it was a 200 million dollar undertaking
that gave the public a modernized
inviting look into the vastness of the
universe and his work well that extended
way beyond the planetarium in 2001 he
received a presidential appointment to
work on policies related to the future
of the u.s. space industry after that he
was part of the Commission to work on
the future of space exploration his
service on these committees was so
impressive that NASA gave him the
distinguished Public Service Medal
Tyson's scientific work as well as
decisions he made about the Hayden
Planetarium put him in the spotlights
for the general public well beyond those
normally in the scientific community he
actually became a household name because
of one particular decision and what did
he do well he removed the planet of
Pluto from the planetarium solar system
display school children parents and
scientists alike were not impressed with
his decision and soon it became more
about just the planetariums display
Pluto's fate it was taken up by an
international organization the
International Astronomical Union in 2006
the organization made their stance on
Pluto official when they deemed Pluto a
dwarf planet officially knocking our
solar system down
only eight planets so well the question
might be now well what does Tyson
maintain is so wrong with Pluto well for
one it has the potential to grow a tail
yes that is a legitimate reason and here
is the man himself explaining it so
Pluto is not the littlest planet or
right that alone that shouldn't hurt it
but more than half of its volume is ice
no other planet has that so if you moved
its to where earth is right now heat
from the Sun would evaporate the ice and
it would grow a tail that's no kind of
behavior for a planet add to that
Pluto's orbit is much more elongated
than that of the other planets and it's
so small that the other planets have
moons that are larger than Pluto and
you're beginning to see why he falls on
the Pluto is not a planet offense
now the pletely thing was one of the
most famous maybe infamous scientific
sessions of Tysons career indeed he has
written articles essays and even books
that discuss in much more detail the
demotion of this planet how this worked
was he wrote for National History
Magazine in the 1990s and his columns
were later turned into two different
books these were death by black hole and
astrophysics for people in a hurry
he chose the pen name of Merlin for
himself when he wrote a column in the
stardate magazine and those columns they
were also later published as books
Tyson hasn't just used publications do
you spread the word about science in the
universe he's hosted TV shows he
regularly appears as a guest on other
shows and he has his own podcast called
star talk he hosted Nova ScienceNOW in
the mid-2000s raising his profile even
further to most Americans he was so
popular as a host that in 2014 the
network brought him back to delve even
further into science for the American
people the 2014 show gave Tyson an
opportunity to build on the work of a
man who had impacted him early on and
that would be Carl Sagan while a show it
was cosmos a new version of the popular
on the Sega nerd hosted in the 1980s at
the time of its airing cosmos was the
most watched show in the United States
but if there was anyone who could live
up to these kind of expectations well
that would be Tyson he didn't have to go
it alone in 2014 though he had the help
of Sagan's Widow he worked as a writer
for cosmos and the team made sure to
include allusions to Sagan's work
throughout the rebooted series the
series it was a success and over 3
million Americans put their TV onto Fox
to catch the newest science lesson
presented by Tyson every Sunday for 13
weeks the cosmos reboot was undoubtedly
successful and showed Tyson's appeal to
the general populace but his appeal in
the media well it goes well beyond
direct and serious science he's appeared
as a guest on Family Guy Brooklyn
nine-nine and his character in new Ice
Age The Big Bang Theory with its a nerdy
cast has of course welcomes Tyson as a
guest he even made an appearance on
Avenged Sevenfold's album this stage he
didn't sing but instead delivered a
monologue during one of the Bands songs
a musical adherence that was rumored to
happen that never actually came about
was that Tyson would appear on an album
with wu-tang clan member dizzer though
the appearance never happens it does
speak to Tyson's breadth of talents and
popularity that many people thought it
was a very probable thing for Tyson to
do while the album didn't happen Tyson
and RZA did appear together winches are
wrapped on Startalk even The Daily Show
has regularly featured Tyson to comment
on science matters and as he did with
Pluto Tyson makes
no bones about sharing his thoughts on
what needs to be corrected indeed live
on re informed John Stewart the
beginning of your program the earth is
spinning at the wrong direction I'm
sorry I had to get that off my chest the
earth on the credits was spinning
clockwise when Earth really spins
counterclockwise though Tyson pointed it
out to Stuart in the entire viewing
audience it wasn't until Trevor Noah
took over as host in 2015 that the show
made a permanent correction to the earth
spinning direction Tyson was excited
about the change and tweeted out his
thanks to The Daily Show
Daily Show's globe is in the only
direction that Tyson's scientific
knowledge has led to in the realm of pop
culture well you might remember that
1997 blockbuster movie Titanic
well Tyson saw it and he wasn't
impressed near the end after the ship is
sunk Rose is lying on a board in the
freezing Atlantic Ocean she's gazing up
in the night sky and the audience can
see what she sees the stars in the sky
over the ocean when Tyson saw their
scene he noticed something that the rest
of us didn't while the stars they
weren't in the right arrangement for the
year 1912 at the latitude and longitude
where the Titanic sunk so as with a
Daily Show Tyson let director David
Cameron know according to Cameron
Tyson sending a snarky email on the
subject fifteen years after that film
was first released camera and took
Tyson's suggestion and adjusted the
night sky in that scene in order to be
accurate Titanic in The Daily Show
weren't enough for Tyson
he's even had a hand in keeping Superman
scientifically accurate DC Comics wanted
to feature the world's most famous
astrophysicist in a comic but Tyson
wouldn't do it unless he could be sure
of the accuracy with the distance
Krypton is supposed to be from Earth
Tyson said he would never be able to
help Superman spot it so well what did
he do well he did his research and found
an actual red star to service Krypton
and crafted a story where my Superman
would combine all the telescopes on
earth to be able to see Krypton
so no media format has been untouched by
Tyson the man is everywhere spreading
the word of science and the people of
the world while we're listening creators
and producers take his advice and seek
him out for appearances among scientists
is unique in this kind of stardom
a serious scientist in pop culture
figure would seem to make any person
interesting enough but Tyson has hobbies
and interests that go well beyond the
mysteries of space and the sharing of
science he and his wife Alice who he met
in a physics class are both foodies
Tyson has said they probably spend too
much money on food but living in
Manhattan they have so many restaurants
to explore and so many food options to
try out that they take every opportunity
they can to try new foods Tyson he's
also a wine connoisseur his love of
science plays a big role in his
enjoyment of wine helping him to
understand why different wine tastes
difference and how they dust can be
served like much else
Tyson explains these concepts simply so
that non scientists can understand them
to the lower than 32 degrees freezing
points of liquids that contain alcohol
like wine allows you to chill a bottle
of white wine to sub-freezing
temperatures without it freezing before
you bring it to a dinner party the wine
warms up during the travel time to just
the right temperature in time for dinner
indeed a rather well known scientist as
the source of Tyson's favorite quote
about food and wine and that would be
Galileo the Sun with all those planets
revolving around it and dependent on it
can still ripen a bunch of grapes as if
it had nothing else in the universe to
do food wine physics well what's left
for him to care about and learn about
well calligraphy for one Tyson can
create beautiful lettered art with a
feathered pen but is especially
passionate about fountain pens he loves
them so much that his wife spent $6,000
to buy him a Japanese maid pen as a gift
when he finalized the contracts on his
autobiography he even gave an entire
interview to the New York Times on the
pen and his love of calligraphy in the
interview he described his own
mathematical theory behind how you can
tell if a pen is perfect for calligraphy
having to dip the pen in ink after every
8 to 10 words means you're writing with
a beautiful rhythm he says
he's passionate about life and
everything in it he's passionate about
science in the world knows it with all
that he's accomplished in his life and
the celebrity status he's achieved it
would be easy to excuse Tyson for having
a large ego but he doesn't in fact
he takes special pains to point out the
danger of ego if your ego starts out I'm
important I am big I am special you're
in for some disappointments when you
look around it what we've discovered
about the universe no you're not big no
you're not you're small in time and
space and you have this frail vessel
called the human body that's limited on
earth perhaps this attitude is a large
part of his success and why he is so
beloved for all his intelligence and his
contributions to the study of space Neil
deGrasse Tyson remains firmly planted
with two feet right here on earth so I
really hope you enjoyed the video if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday
and if you've got a suggestion for us
would you like to see us make a
biographic Svidler well please do join
in the comment section below and let us
know what you thought of this video as
well we're always looking to improve and
make these videos better and we can only
do that with your help and feedback so
please do get involved in the comments
and as always thank you for watching